hello to everyone we're going to start
our analyze this class at the Chess Club
elastic Center of st. Louis so basically
this is the class where we're going to
go over the games of members of the st.
Louis chess club and all I'll try to
give some useful feedback on these games
our first game is an oak alley Sicilian
Knight f3 a6 this is a pretty rare
remove for black and fortunately a
little bit about it because I play this
as black as well as a surprise weapon
and I even won um a key game in my chest
career with this move in the 2007 US
Women's Championship in the last round I
had a must win situation I was black
against Tottenham Abraham ham and I
played this move um you know it's a
pretty interesting move to play against
an open Sicilian player because it makes
it difficult for white to play an open
Sicilian that's basically what this move
is about you know white is some
aggressive v4 player who wants to play
the open Sicilian with d 4e 6 is a
pretty good anti-node against up because
White's um main options against this
move are really not d4 he's got to go to
other paths so what are some other moves
white can make here other than d4
keyboard for you think c4 is good yeah
c4 so that's been played against me as
well go into this kind of Roxy fine what
else
so I'll explain why the ideas move a6
the O'Kelly Sicilian the idea is let's
say white plays d4 what happens in the
game block takes takes well first of all
you can include the move Knight f6
that's kind of more accurate um so
making a little attack on this pawn
notice how this pawn can advance get
because of a very typical move between
a5 double attack check and attack on
this pawn wins a pawn for black so
you've got to protect this poem with
some move like Knight c3 or Bishop d3
and hear you play e5 so you're kind of
um you're carrying out this one typical
idea for black in the Sicilian just e5
move and you also haven't committed your
knight to c6 yet you've made pawn to a6
move instead controlling this square so
very often Sicilian with at night is
attacked the knight will go to b5 as you
notice here doesn't have that square so
it's forced to go somewhere else and the
other point is you haven't moved your D
pawn so that your Bishop is actually
still free to come out on that diagonal
so I think if they play Knight well
they're a couple of moves here for white
there's there's negative five there's 93
there's negative three if they go here
there's always an issue of that night
hanging in a tactical way which allows
blocks to play this move D 593 allows
this Bishop to be developed more
aggressively to b4 so he goes outside of
the pawn chain and you have not only d6
but also d5 ideas kind of depends on
what white does and Knight f3
trying to remember the theory here in 96
seems reasonable but I feel like you can
also look at this move this move
probably works as well if you take here
there's a little problem 25
yeah it's still interesting because you
can play 27 for example defending the
meats threatened f7 and when they take
into something like decent poops no you
don't want to do that first you lose
your Bishop but if you take take and
play D 6 or even knight c6 kind of
interesting because
it looks like you know get that night on
85 back um well that's one of the things
that block and look at the move Bishop
before here immediately after night of
three and I would think actually there's
a lot of options for block you're not
only Knight takes e4 you can throw in
the move Queen e7 right away and that
move actually makes a lot of sense just
putting pressure on on the key file
immediately we can get rid of this arrow
um so you're going to get back that key
for pawn soon so one of the main ideas
of the O'Kelly is basically this d5 move
not having blocked in your dark squared
bishop and that's why makes it hard for
white to just play an open Sicilian I
think a tricky move here is a move like
93 which basically I can force his
blocks to go into an e6 Sicilian it was
probably blacks best move there's a move
b5 but this is a dangerous for black and
the other main move is going to c3
Sicilian also makes a lot of sense for
white because you're saying while you're
playing a c3 Sicilian you've got in the
Moon Knight f3 black has the move Knight
a6 in and out of three is probably more
useful so black usually goes into this
isolated pawn type of position and I've
I've had to all play that as black as
well but so a six um not in amazing move
but it's certainly effective from
stopping white playing the open Sicilian
in this game why play the open Sicilian
so what wasn't deterred he went from
this line anyway and now we saw a knight
of six attacking the pawn and then he
five would have been the best way for
black to play black played this move
right away is there any big difference
well so for I don't see it I see it
okay
what why is this move right away less
accurate the night of six why is it
better for block to include the move 906
we've actually seen it so you guys
should be able to figure it out
space because of 92
well did you notice how negative six we
were attacking this pawn and okay this
is one you know the best moves for white
and then you were always getting pinned
in this unfortunate way and that's a AB
null so you were basically forcing the
Negev that's where you know with that
with if you play e5 right away
okay this move looks reasonable I don't
know if 93 or 99 f3 is better I know
that night of five always runs into the
typical move d5 and you're efore pawn is
overloaded so I wouldn't I wouldn't
suggest that for white so let's say you
go negative three the main difference is
that there's nothing to pin on before
that's unfortunate for black lets up the
end of the world on a big deal Knight f6
uh-huh tricky now this pawn that looks
like this attacks is actually not
attacks
yeah I guess it's kind of similar you
can't take this pawn because of Queen a5
winning the night
so what has to figure out a way to
defend d4 Bishop d3 makes some sense
I can see you know 93 you don't want to
play that because it shouldn't be for
and I would consider this move certainly
a decent I'll turn it up to 93 or 92 I
mean 92 it can't be a great movie frame
then it's a possible move it can't be
that critical it's obviously a very
positive way of developing the night so
I'm sure black is going to get a good
game after that blackface 96 that makes
sense to me um developing a piece for
secretary 5 and being flexible as to
what we're going to do the team con dish
of d3 d5 okay
I mean you deserves choose to play with
this pawn on the board or trading this
pawn so you can consider I think I move
like Bishop c5 you can take a look at
that move that's also one of the
benefits of the old Kelly again because
you haven't pushed that pawn out early
your bishop can it develop along that
diagonal ship c5 try to play with d6
with your Bishop outside of the pawn
chain it seems like a reasonable plan
for blush but certainly d5 can't be a
mistake white castles
this should be seven so seems reasonable
I mean the game seems pretty balanced
right now
Ricky one there is some pressure on that
pawn so white wants to capture on d5 and
capture that pawn for that reason black
plays d4 so d4 is a pretty committal
decision I think after rook e1 my point
is d4 is not an obvious move to me
that's not an obvious decision that I
would make for black because I think the
main point of this you know advance of
the pawn is definitely to try to trade
that if you think about it you're trying
to trade off this pawn for this pawn so
pawn on g7 for a central pawn on e4 and
you're going for the four on three
majority on the Kings side so when you
get a chance to do that here I would
certainly think about that d4 leaves the
e4 pawn on the board
mmm okay so it's a possible decision but
I think this move is certainly going to
give black a decent game any questions
about that boys report what do you think
starfish like stop Fishlegs d4 okay well
if you like taking this basic manner it
doesn't seem like you know this isn't
like a bad move to me just doesn't seem
obvious either for the decision okay
ninety-four
pawns attack Bishop g4 another way to
protected is Queen c7
if there's of g4 also is kind of a
committal way to protect the pawn I mean
Queen c7 is the sort of the
non-committal way to protects it right
now you still have the ideas of b5 here
with Bishop g4 h3 you're kind of setting
yourself for either having to trade the
bishop for the knights or retreating it
and allowing white to play moves like
that then you've got to be ready to sack
a knight for two pawns which I don't
think is enough in this position I think
we can actually unpin with a move like
that and this doesn't seem like the kind
of position where that piece sacrifice
for two pawns is quite enough so I'm not
sure about the move Bishop g4 because I
think it's setting us up to trade off
our Bishop for a knight much or the best
thing and I'm I'm also a little bit
worried guys about you know when we
trade off for LightSquared bishop we've
got a lot of pawns and dark squares
we've got a dark squared Bishop so I'm
worried about the future of not peace
Bishop g4 it seems like a questionable
decision to me it's not fun obvious
thing so yeah block decided to trade
because I guess they didn't like the
prospect of having to sacrifice their
piece here by the way
yes if the pin is broken then Y can
simply cap to that central pawn so
that's what luck didn't like and black
um made the capture instead
yeah I don't like that turn of events
for luck um simply yeah I mean you have
to get you have to have a good reason to
get me Bishop here especially the better
part of your bishop pair which was I
think the LightSquared Bishop because I
don't see a whole lot of future for this
bishop in this game but we'll see let's
see what happens b5 mean black is
obviously still okay no they've got some
space advantage in the center they don't
have any you know terrible pieces so the
game continues 92 it's forced castles a4
interesting move by white anything else
that comes to one eye like a for trying
to ask block what he wants to do about
that pawn if he wants to advance it then
maybe white gets the c-4 square if he
takes of course an a4 then the rook
comes into the game a6 becomes a week um
follow me a4 is interesting I guess
block is also a lot of choices there's
b4 there's Queen b6 and just defend the
pawn I mean really you can just don't
you can do a lot of things it's not
exactly even like taking with maybe not
my favorite option but you can still
consider it with this idea of 94 and
maybe this is not a reason and with the
idea of 97 somewhere 93 and 95 still
looks acceptable for black I mean I
didn't love the idea of giving up a
LightSquared Bishop but my still has a
decent position before mmm worried about
that square before is not the kind of
the first move I play and that's for
sure what else is an interesting move
here guys
that's unusual more unusual I I've given
you the standard moves first kind of
more usual move just black out here I
don't know if it's good what is that
really
yeah I was thinking about that trying to
pin the a pawn this way
well see that's the whole point yeah
there's no night b3 because you lose the
rook you could play B through me I
really just want to take the pawn a4
without being protected that's sort of
my idea it's not the end of the world I
mean you could play something like B
three sectors really like screen b6 he
likes Queen b6 here yeah it's like a
normal move so the first one that gave
you the ones that don't really quite
require like a lot of you know
imagination they just look like a good
solid moves Queen b6 you connect your
rooks you protect your pawn and don't
give up the c-4 square so before all
right
well block still alive Queen e2
marketing a6
I would think about 94 as well it's hard
for white to sort of not play this move
at some point it seems like the knight
should occupy that square I don't see
what else where's the knight gotta go
where's Bishop it's not easy to get the
bishop there there's always like 95 and
if your knight somewhere else and the
bishop goes back to a - there's always
be three ideas so I would think about
this move as well starting with that
alright let's see what happens after
Queen - I guess that's my guess but how
block will protect the pawn Queen six
there's ninety four tempo a five
probably a five you know I think blacks
kind of went with a strategy of giving
up his light squares have been putting a
lot of pawns on on the dark squares and
I think at this point okay this is what
happens yeah I mean I don't see too much
of a downside of putting yet another
pawn on the dark squares but you know
fine block guys you've got to be a
little bit concerned about how many
pawns you're going to put on the dark
squares when you've got a dark squared
Bishop so I am concerned about these
files you know especially the C 4 square
sure what okay white played 93 they want
to target 85 s that what I would do
probably not
I'm sure the night is really that well
placed here us to a plan for a white
that's the the difficult part kind of
plan should we meet
okay yeah why don't you try I think the
night on c4 think that's to actual the
natural home for the night which part of
the board should white be playing for
playing on Jason I think so I think the
kingside I think this is the sort of the
natural plan for whites to play that for
get that dark squared Bishop into the
game open up that light squared Bishop
on XIII play T five if you get a chance
and I think the night on c4 is just know
very effective and now it's hard for
block to remove it once that pawn
especially on a five there's no there's
no 985 there's no way to remove that
night I mean okay yeah I knew that
didn't want to play but I can't play
Knight e5 let's remove the night biggest
decision yeah well you know you're in a
quandary here because you now there's a
weakness okay you don't have a bishop to
guard it on you know c8 or b7 so you
either have to tie down pieces to it
which is not ideal right I mean you know
playing Queen b6 not ideal you're
letting this move come with a tempo
maybe you can do it maybe maybe that's
not so bad and your queen protects me
five so you still have nine five ideas
and maybe that um a five yeah I can take
not an ideal paw information for black
block has too many starting to get to
any weakness than the light squares and
by the way there's one piece that's
particularly bad in this position
notice this piece how you can put you
managed to put pawns to surround him
that he has no place to go to I would
worry about that I'm worried about blue
block is doing with the fish upon you
seven and the knight on c6
alright so Knight b3 I don't think
that's the right square for the knight
because I think it's not that hard for
block to protect a5 and I think your
general idea is to play here and I mean
you can't find something for this night
to do on b3 I mean you know maybe one
day you'll put your work here at
pressure d4 but I still think the knight
would be more sort of powerful on cc4
maybe you can make a case for somehow
leaving that score for the bishop so
we'll see I'm just telling you my
instincts 97 f4 so this happened
black/white is trying to open up the
position for his bishops 97 I think 97
is a good move now the knight clearly
has nothing to do on f6 it's time to
transfer it and
and I may bring it to c5 make that trade
although I do like White's position now
that for is the right time to platform
you're giving up the e5 square I don't
know if we need to play a four right now
because black is positioned there Knight
perfectly to jump into that square so
should we be playing this move at the
moment I'm not sure take stakes here
that's an interesting positional
decision not bad yeah kind of feeling
like f4 is coming too early but I can
see yeah black wants to trade off there
there bishop dumping one who comes into
consideration here for white what else
can we consider doing after ninety seven
other than f4
eat efficiently five doesn't really
change anything in any fundamental way
you can do that I can play we're seeing
you're not threatening to take because
I'm still protecting a five with mine
there should be five as possible what
else but I would be concerns about luck
what just happened
Oh
I'd be concerned about block carrying
out this idea of trading off his poor
dark-squared bishop what measures can we
take to prevent that I mean you can't
put a knight on f3 anymore to guard for
Chi 5 so ever Queen h5 interesting range
5 I didn't think about that but it's
interesting
not a bad square for the Queen
especially if you're planning to play it
for one day actually it's a pretty good
square control g5 your attack age 7 so
when you play five there's kind of six
or anything
h6 renewing oh yeah you can do that yeah
you can renew the threat efficiency
yeah I don't see anything wrong with the
movie h6 here there's no I don't think
there's any bishop sacrifice there at
the moment that works basically I would
think about this move guys as a
prophylactic move for white whether you
want to do it with Queen age five or
before Queen age five I would think
about it because you know I'm looking at
blacks position and his main idea is to
trade off this bad bishop everyone
understands why this bishop is bad
you've got a lot of pawns in the dark
squares and you've got a dark squared
bishop so you want to trade it off and I
would think about a move like that
because on Bishop g5 my idea is to play
a four and recapture with a pawn not
with the bishop given that I'm going to
get some two strong pawns here supported
by my bishop pair you know I would think
that white is doing well in a position
like that you know if you take I take
that's what I'm going for here work back
I would prefer white here so I would
think about making a move like g3 I
don't know we can see what the computer
says what is it what is our little
friend said there should be fives one of
the moves he looks at and then what does
he want to do after that he doesn't like
f4 TC he immediately changes the
evaluation to even so it's kind of
coming too early so he's looking for
some other moves no if we could just get
rid of that so I can see what actual
line he's showing here some say what
does he want to do after Bishop b5 org
c8 let's say queen g4 so he's taking
measures to stop Bishop g5 yeah should
what about Bishop why is he looking at
this move because of the pawn hanging
yeah you can't trade here quite yet
because your pawn a5 hangs there is that
issue although pretty interesting or g6e
I don't think you have enough
compensation there all right
well let's go back a little bit I don't
know from a human point of view I think
g3 makes sense so f4 coming too early I
think this is what black is looking for
because it first of all black is
perfectly positioned to put a knight on
e5 and I like this move Bishop g5 as
well it's a good positional decision
offering a trade of those bishops
and later on you're going to occupy the
square and I can see black even being
better here so that's how unfortunate I
think is this early move f4 which leads
the which is probably going to lead to
the trade of those dark-squared bishop
yeah that's what happened it's hard to
avoid that trade now because if you try
to avoid it you know the bishop gets a
good square in III and you also you know
it's hard to get rid of it so but I
think this turn of events is definitely
in Black's favor black has a great
outpost for their knight in the center
and you have a LightSquared bishop and
now you've got a lot of pawns on the
light squares so that was good for block
okay maybe probably a good decision to
get rid of that Bishop you could also
consider by the way this move I would
look at that with the idea of
transferring that Bishop to d5 pretty
good square actually for the bishop
targeting here targeting here yeah I
like the move Bishop c4 it's kind of a
more aggressive move something like that
the bishop is pretty powerful where he
is and then you can consider rob1 and
Knight takes d4 the pawn becomes a bit
weak Queen f2 if you need to attack it
again actually I still kind of like
white after the move Bishop c4 this
should be five maybe any questions guys
no okay
Nady five d1 okay make sense or tucking
the pawn
okay tricky move you want to win a pawn
if there's an exchange of Queens pawn
takes and the nice attacked and that
pawn is a text that is White's idea he
wants to win a pawn Knight e5 aha
tricky response so there's a tactic here
guys now related to that square so that
if white takes that pawn black captures
on d4 white captures Knight check King
somewhere Queen takes Queen here and
black wins apiece that's blacks idea so
85 is a good little tricky move
that's why white moved their King away
how does black protect that D pawn seems
to me like black is in a little bit of
trouble here because he's got that pawn
hanging this pawn hanging the Knights
pinned hmm I would say that black is
looking to be worse here you're
wondering probably how I'm changing my
evaluations like so quickly that any
particular reason like first I say
blacks better but I say blacks worse I
don't really say where the mistake came
from okay let me try that again let me
see if I could make a more logical
explanation of what just happened so I
feel like you know white was better in
this position this move I do think it
kind of gives black a relief and I'm
happy to see the trade of those bishops
however you know we still have that
problem with the D pawn d4 pawn I like
the move Bishop c4 Bishop b5 my feeling
is like blacks should be able to do
something here now this move yet that
makes sense anything else we can do okay
let's try this
okay here here so you want to win that
pawn rook D it all right takes takes and
Queen B five and I still don't really
see a solution for block doing uh-huh
what if black simply defended that night
that might make some sense what a block
just made a move like this maybe this
was more solid for block because you've
got the D pawn protected
you've got your knight protected so the
main idea of this move is simply to
protect a knife you've got your a pawn
protected hmm for black yes I mean I
might look for counter play with with
this rook which is the only piece that
can sort of move like rook a to b i'm
probably going to try to kick out your
queen and so my idea like let me just
show you some general moves I'll make a
path for white so I want to try to use
this rook now you move here I want to
try to put it here so I am going to try
to get counter play here now you're
going to take this pawn and I was hoping
that I could do something unfortunately
if I take take I can't take this pawn
because this rook is hanging so that
idea doesn't quite work so do I have any
dangerous discovered attacks here on the
Queen I don't see them so maybe I can't
do them yeah I mean there are different
ideas you can also play Queen f6 to
defend the knight you've got it you know
this is the kind of moment that it's not
like so easy to figure out like
immediately the difference between Queen
g6 and queen h6 and Queen f6 like all of
them do that um it seems reasonable
Queen f6
'if I've not such a big problem because
now I go here and I would think that if
you advance your epon just the counter
play against c2 would be helpful for
black uh-huh okay you want to go east
six that's a big problem I can take on
c2
all right now it gets really dangerous
for black but let me try that move which
one rook c1 I want to take the knight
well you want to try to maybe get my
king out I would think that you'd want
to expose my king right I was thinking I
could take then the King just runs to g8
so I was cut I was thinking I could
survive this position although I agree
that it looks very perilous for black
one Queen B seven after King G after
Queen d7 G no what's that what's that
you want sure but you're not better
there in fact you're probably if
anything you're going to be worse there
right because I'm just going to take and
after you take I don't have to take your
rook I can just do Queen c5 and I mean
certainly blacks not worse here why it's
the one who's going to be worse here
because he's pinned and he's going to
have to be careful not to lose to this
move wins the game look at that remember
that work that you wanted to take you
can take
okay we've got a little discovered check
the winds the Queen okay well I'm just
saying I don't know I do agree this
position looks dangerous for black I
don't love bringing my King out in the
center I'm not sure that it's completely
losing for black um what's my bet on
what the computer would say about this
um I would say the computer would say
that it's bad for black probably after
some move like nice c5 let's see it's
computer six it says completely winning
for white just first well Knight 81 well
that's a move I couldn't even consider a
second move that I did I did consider
was Knight c5 a little bit more natural
you know to move forward rather than
backwards now we can try to figure out
why this move would be winning what is
so wonderful about this move what is
even the idea of this retreat well he's
attacking the Queen and moving away his
knight from attack after this move okay
I see what he wants to do is when we
keep our knight protected he wants to
give that check and keep our King in the
center yeah well when our king is not
allowed to go back to F to g8 I agree
that it's going to be bad news yeah so
night night a1 okay that's a strong move
I had a feeling like something is wrong
with our King coming out into the open
that's a good idea you v e6
Queen b5 yeah I mean I don't know what
has the initiative I agree with that you
know white saw I what is our week
computer program so he says Knight e5
and how does he want to exactly defend
that pawn wait what happened after King
H won Queen g3 that's what happened okay
well let's continue then all right so he
likes he likes the move Knight e5
threatening Knight f3 King h1 and Queen
g3 okay nice way to defend the d4 pawn
you can't take the pawn because of rook
d4 and your rook on e 1 is hanging so
that doesn't work
ok nice and also you're threatening to
get rid of your weakness on d4 now black
is looking pretty good again in my
clueless analysis ah Queen e2 should
have played up you didn't play that what
did you play but that's what the game
says this is how it went oh you should
have played d3 that's where you put the
arrow yeah you could have gotten rid of
that weakness right away it just seems
like a simple and good move right all
right rook here yeah it's not really
going anywhere is it it's not really
going anywhere in the 6th now we lost
that pawn that was unfortunate and then
okay we're threatening mate I would play
rook f1 know someone happen Knight a5
pretty good too I was thinking could
even do that guard f2 square 9 of 5
Queen g5
which four wins because you're chopping
the queen or something and then you want
to play 97 and rookie five yeah
so what are we in whites butter whites
up a pawn to the white win this end game
whites up a pawn and blacks King is
weaker so that's a big advantage for
white here mmm
what do you guys think about that
decision
sure white trade so I trade Queens like
who's King is weaker so if blacks King
is a weaker why is white trading Queens
I was worried that see - sure well how
about this move then keep your C pawn
protected but you know keep this King
keep the Queens on the board for this
King I mean like look you have ideas of
attacking that King the King seems
weaker than your King plus your Queen
seems very active you know like I don't
know in this position I wouldn't be in a
hurry to trade Queens at all because you
know they say rook a lot of rook end
games are drawn and being down a pawn in
a rook endgame is not such a big deal
like if I was black I would feel like by
you trading Queens I'd be bailing out
into something safer like I'd feel more
confident I could draw that position
because I'm only down upon in a rook
endgame that's not a big material
deficit that's not like a big reason why
I can't draw but if the Queen's are on
the board and I not only have to worry
about being down upon but I also have to
worry about my King safety because my
King is weaker I don't know why I don't
see any reason not to keep the Queens on
the board I guess what are you worried
about like the rook coming here is
something some active move like this
yeah I mean I didn't
sure you know you have different ideas
of getting you know rook to the G file
even like a check like on e1 King goes
away and it seems pretty safe so yeah I
understand you're not analyzing much I'm
saying - I didn't analyze much either
but my impression is that by trading
you're making it easier for black to
play because a general idea is that if
you are um if you have enough if your
opponent's king is weaker than yours you
try to keep the Queen's on the board
that's all it's not a matter of analysis
it's just you know if you don't like
this move then you can make this move if
you you know it's the same idea I just
think your chances of winning or better
if you keep the Queen's on the board
because you know black always has to
worry about the King and it's weaker
than whites King so this move I feel
like okay suddenly I'm getting chances
to draw again in fact I'd be fun you
know pretty happy here is black rook c1
yeah you want to put the room behind the
past pawn right to push it that's
interesting yeah it's kind of an
interesting move yeah I mean it's
unusual it's unusual but you know you
want to play something like c4 and just
have the rook behind the past pawn where
it's well positioned I can see that
okay I mean like it's hard to activate
this rook right because you're just
going here and I think if I go here even
just advancing the pawn it's probably
just quite dangerous because it just
goes forward supported by the rook from
behind and black is not in time to stop
it you know I'm not in time to go here
and and put a rook here so looks like a
pretty good move I mean I like that move
it's that idea of you know rooks behind
belong behind past pawn so you're passed
pawn is a few pawn you want to push in
you're putting the work there up so I
like that move King f8 okay
c4 I would take yeah rook takes keys
would be a yeah
be three fun yeah this is just the kind
of position you know I wouldn't be so
happy to get his block first why don't
see the point of that was that this is
really passive right so we just just
visually guys like this rook is you know
on this open semi open file instead of
it's going passively to eight it's not
the kind of move I would even think
about not mean White has good winning
chances here what can I say but still in
a rook endgame you always have some sort
of leeway rook a eight passive King
comes up work here okay the rook is in a
good position on b5 here so I think
Black has got some too passive
the real
so who won this yeah I mean this is kind
of looking like it's like bad news for
black when this work is so active and
this work is so passive so that's the
kind of thing you really can't afford
yourself when you're down material is
then you're down material plus you're
getting so passive so I would never put
that rook on a8 and try to hold that
position like that better to arm like
here this position I mean it's a key
moment so for everything is okay so you
played beat Rugby 8 B 3 um what would I
do is black let me try to hold this
position nothing's really being
threatened yet unless you move your king
over here then your rook can get active
all right
so okay King e7 now what but in a rook
endgame you know there's a reason why
it's said that all rook and games are
drawn it's because even being down upon
and a rook endgame is not such a big
disadvantage right so but the main thing
is you got to keep your pieces active if
you're you know your rook you know you
can trade the b-pawn for the a pawn it's
not like oh my opponent has the past
pawn so I'm going to look lose the rook
endgame that's not the right way to look
at it yes that is a possible trade and
the reality is you can hold tons of work
end games like that when your opponent
has some past pawn especially if your
work gets to be behind the pass pawn and
their work is in front of it that's a
good scenario for making a draw like I
recently had a had a game like that on
that was down upon and a rook end gave
me a pawn like against a Vaughn choke
and you know my rook was well positioned
behind the past pawn his rook was in
front of it and there were pawns on the
Kings side and you know he couldn't make
any progress so the main thing to
remember is to keep your pieces active
and even if the these pawns are traded
to try to get your rook behind the past
pawn where it's stopping the pawn and
also targeting the King side pawns that
would be a grade square for it and
meanwhile if that's not happening
well just
you know just never this move never
should cross your mind ever I'm sorry
just that it's a very instructive
mistake and the lesson is you can't play
the rook endgame passively especially
when you're down material you know
what's your only chance well keep your
pieces active like I said it's okay to
be down a pawn in a rook endgame um from
the point of view of making a draw as
long as your pieces are active look you
know you can get so much counter play
it's so difficult for your opponent to
win to figure out you know what he
should do he's got to hold on to his
King side pawns he's got to figure out I
make a pawn breakthrough I mean well I
mean of course it's not easy right he's
got this idea he can try to win a second
pawn that's why actually white winning a
second pawn is much more dangerous than
white trading off the a pawn for the D
pawn that's actually a more dangerous
idea like this yeah if you go here he
goes here and you're forced to kind of
protect the pawn like that well he can
try that yeah the King you know this
check that King goes up it's not so
pleasant no maybe we should do it how
can we do it so the plan White's plan is
to come support that pawn with a king
and free up the rook and attack the a
pawn okay that's why it's plan so we've
got to figure out some way to stop that
that's why my first intention really was
to activate this rook like that and so
if you're going here then I want to go
here and I want to put my rook here
where it stops your King from moving
without you having to you know worry
about your King side so you might okay
you could play King g1 rub d2 and then
still go for this type of position
you'll probably have to go for this
sooner or later
now the only difference is I haven't had
time to put my rook here so you still
have a chance to move your rook out from
a five and support the a four pawn from
the side rather than from in front which
is generally better so you can get some
position like this are actually even
better like this so but here I don't
know is it better because maybe I have
that move and I make it hard for your
rook to stay on the fifth-ranked yeah I
mean this is also not like an easy
position for white so when it's like you
know when it gets down to positions like
that it's a lot about precise
calculation like can white you know why
it's not going to be able to promote
that pawn without bringing the king up
when they bring the King up they have to
figure out what's happening when they
sacrifice their King side so it becomes
a you know white also has a little bit
of risk here you know it's not just like
a free you know like it's not like they
have an extra Paul and the more active
wrote the more active King and
everything is a smooth as butter so um
that's the kind of position I strive for
is black if I wanted to save myself and
this type of rook ends game any
questions guys no okay we got one game
you